CNN'S BRIAN TODD IS LIVE IN
WASHINGTON WITH THE VERY LATEST.
IT IS DISTURBING TO PUT IT
MILDLY, BRIAN.
>> RIGHT.
ERICA, THIS INFORMATION COMING
TO US FROM THE CITY OF
CHESAPEAKE.
THE NOTE WAS FOUND ON THE
SHOOTERS PHONE AND OUTLINED THE
GRIEVANCES WITH HIS COLLEAGUES
BUT ALSO WITH HIMSELF.
THE NOTE DISCUSSES GOD, THE HOLY
SPIRIT AND HOW THE AUTHOR FELT
THAT HIS ASSOCIATES AT HIS
WORKPLACE WERE MOCKING HIM.
HERE IS ONE PASSAGE.
THE SASSOCIATES MOCKED ME AND
CELEBRATED MY DOWNFALL THE LAST
DAY.
THAT IS WHY THEY SUFFERED THE
SAME FATE AS ME.
HERE IS ANOTHER QUOTE.
I WISH I COULD HAVE SAVED
EVERYONE FROM MYSELF, MY GOD
FORGIVE ME FOR WHAT I'M GOING TO
DO.
AND IT DISCUSSES HOW THE AUTHOR
WISHES THAT HIS PARENTS PAID
CLOSE TO ATTENTION TO HIS SOCIAL
DEFICITS AND THAT HE FELT HE WAS
LED BY SATAN.
THE ATTACK WAS NOT PLANNED BUT
THE FACT THAT WAS A NOTE
DISCUSSING WHAT HE WAS GOING TO
DO SUGGESTS THAT MAYBE THERE WAS
SOME PLANNING AND CITY OFFICIALS
SAY THE SHOOTER ANDRE BRING USED
A 9 MILLIMETER HANDGUN AND IT
WAS PURCHASED ON THE MORNING OF
THE ATTACK.
AND ALSO WE COULD NOW REPORT
FROM THE CHESAPEAKE POLICE THAT
NONE OF THE NAMES THAT ARE
REDACTED IN THAT DEATH NOTE
BELONG TO ACTUAL VICTIMS KILLED
IN THE SHOOTING.
ERICA.
>> BRIAN TODD, THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS,
JULIE A KAI EM.
LET'S START ON THE NOTE.
IT IS A LIST OF GRIEVANCES.
THERE WERE NAMES IN THERE, THEY
WERE REDACTED AND ALSO EXCUSES
FOR WHAT WAS ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU IN THAT
NOTE?
>> WELL, THE FIRST IS OBVIOUSLY
CONSCIOUSNESS OF WHAT HE'S ABOUT
TO DO AND THEN JUST LEARNING
THAT HE PURCHASED THE GUN THAT
MORNING.
SO THIS IS, THIS IS NOT A MURDER
FROM SOME EMOTIONAL DISRUPTION
ALL OF A SUDDEN.
IT WAS PLANNED OUT AND CLEARLY
THERE ARE PROBABLY LIKELY OTHER
NOTES THAT DESCRIBE HIS
GRIEVANCES AGAINST CO-WORKERS.
I ALSO THINK THAT THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE THAT HE HIGHLIGHTS IN THE
NOTES WERE NOT PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM SIMPLY MEANS THAT HE WALKED
INTO HIS PLACE OF WORK AND
WANTED TO SORT OF EXERT AS MUCH
DAMAGE AS POSSIBLE.
AND HE'S WELL AWARE OF THAT.
I THINK THE QUESTION NOW IS WAS
ANYBODY ELSE -- WHAT KIND OF
COMPLAINTS WERE MADE AGAINST HIM
BY EMPLOYEES TO WALMART AND
OTHERS.
>> IT WILL BE INTERESTING AS WE
LEARN MORE WHETHER SOME OF
THOSE -- SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
WHICH EMPLOYEES AND CO-WORKERS
HAVE EXPRESSED TO OUR TEAMS AT
CNN, WHETHER THEY WERE IN FACT
COMMUNICATING WITH WALMART AND
IF SO, WHAT WAS DONE.
IN TERMS WLHAT ELSE WE LEARNED
THIS MORNING, THE GUN WAS
PURCHASED THAT MORNING.
VIRGINIA DOES NOT HAVE A WAITING
PERIOD AND THERE IS NO LICENSE
OR TRAINING REQUIREMENT FOR A
HANDGUN.
WE ARE SEEING A CHANGE IN THIS
COUNTRY, PROBABLY MOST NOTABLY
IN TEXAS WHERE A LAW WENT INTO
EFFECT LAST YEAR THAT ROLLS BACK
REQUIREMENTS FOR OWNERSHIP.
THERE IS THIS MOVE TO PERMITLESS
CARRY SO IT IS EASIER FOR SPLUN
TO BUY A GUN IN THE HEAT OF THE
MOMENT AND USE IT IN THAT
MOMENT.
>> RIGHT.
RIGHT.
AND WE'VE SEEN IN BOTH THE MASS
SHOOTINGS AND NOW THIS HANDGUN
INSTANCE THAT THE PURCHASE
OCCURS 24, 48, 72 HOURS BEFORE
THE MASS KILLING.
CERTAINLY NOT TWO YEARS BEFORE.
LET'S PUT IT THAT WAY.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE KNOW THE
STATISTICS OF YOUNG MEN AND
THEY'RE AGE IN TERMS OF THE
PURCHASE TO MASS KILLING SHORT
TIME FRAME.
SO THOSE ARE JUST WELL
DOCUMENTED.
SO, ONCE AGAIN, WE ARE AT THE
STAGE WHERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO
TO -- TO MAKE THINGS SAFER, NOT
TO MAKE THINGS SAFE IN THIS
COUNTRY GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF
WEAPONRY ON THE STREETS, BUT TO
MAKE THINGS SAFER WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT DELAYS OR AT LEAST
SOME DEEP BREATHS THAT ARE
ALLOWED BY LAW THAT IF YOU THINK
YOU WANT TO BUY A GUN THAT
MORNING, MAYBE YOU HAVE TO WAIT
48 HOURS, IT SEEMS TO ME, NOT A
BIG ASK OF A NATION WITH THIS
MANY GUNS AND I THINK THAT IS
WHY WE'RE SEEING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GET SO
AGGRESSIVE, SO QUICKLY AFTER
ANOTHER MASS SHOOTING BECAUSE
THE PROOF IS IN THE PUDDING.
I WILL SAY THIS, THAT THE
ELECTION AFTER MAJOR NATIONAL
GUN -- GUN SAFETY LEGISLATION
WENT INTO PLACE, IT SHOWED THAT
MODERATES AND THE YOUNG, WHO WE
CALL LOCKDOWN GENERATION,
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'VE PUT THEM
THERE IN SCHOOLS R, VOTING ON
THIS ISSUE IN WAYS THAT ARE
CONSISTENT WITH MORE GUN
REGULATION.
THE NRA HAD SCARED OFF MANY
MODERATES FROM DOING THIS.
>> SO LET ME ASK YOU THIS,
BECAUSE WE'RE ALMOST OUT OF
TIME.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO YESTERDAY
CALLING AND SAID HE WANTS TO
BRING BACK AT SALT WEAPONS BAN.
REALISTICALLY, IT IS UNLIKELY
THAT WILL HAPPEN GIVEN WHERE
THIS COUNTRY IS POLITICALLY.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT COULD BE
DONE?
THE MOST RECENT NUMBERS FROM
2020 ACCORDING TO THE FIREARM
TRADE ASSOCIATION, MORE THAN 24
MILLION WEAPONS OF WAR IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WHAT DO YOU DO AT THIS POINT?
YOU'RE NOT BANNING THEM AND TO
YOUR POINT, THERE IS A LOT
ALREADY OUT THERE.
>> RIGHT.
OKAY, SO YOU FIRST KEEP TRYING
TO BAN THEM.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE POLITICAL
MOMENTUM IS CLEARLY SHOWING THAT
INDEPENDENTS AND GENERATION
LOCKDOWN WHO CAME OUT IN NUMBERS
THIS LAST ELECTION, MAY CONTINUE
TO COME OUT ON THIS ISSUE.
SO THEY ARE VIEWING GUN
LEGISLATION AS SERIOUSLY AS
PRO-GUN ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN
VIEWING IT.
SO THAT IS WHAT THE POLITICS IS
AND IT JUST TOOK A WHILE TO
CATCH UP.
AND THE SECOND IS DELAY IN THE
AGES.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET THE WEAPONS
OFF THE STREET BUT IN THE
SHORT-TERM IF YOU COULD GET BOTH
STATE OR NATIONAL LEGISLATION TO
PROHIBIT 18 TO 25-YEAR-OLDS OR
21-YEAR-OLDS FROM PURCHASING
THIS WEAPONRY, YOU WILL LIMIT
THE NUMBER OF MASS KILLINGS.
AGAIN, WE'RE NOT GOING TO STOP
EVERYTHING.
BUT WHY WOULDN'T YOU TRY TO --
TO AT LEAST TRY TO GET THINGS
SAFER THAN THEY HAVE BEEN.
AND THE DATA IS JUST CLEAR, JUST
LOOKING AT THE DATA, THAT 18 TO
25-YEAR-OLD MALE BRACKET, THEY
SHOULD NOT BE HAVING THESE GUNS,
PERIOD.
THERE IS JUST NO REASON TO.
>> STOPPING ONE, SAVING ONE LIFE
WOULD BE ENOUGH TO HAVE THAT
SERIOUS DISCUSSION.
JULIA, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
THANKS.